Okay.
Hey, what's going on? It's Bill Burr and it's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday. Monday morning podcast and
ahhh
checking in on. Yeah. I'm just checking in on you. How are you?
How's your week going? I hope you're, uh, I hope you're accomplishing things.
I hope you have a sense of purpose. I hope that, uh, that
Douche with the bad breath and the fucking terminal head cold,
that current doesn't walk by your cubicle today.
You know him fucking coming down the fucking hall.
Um, anyways, I am in a a, I'm in a great mood. Believe it or not, I just,
uh, I finally got, did I tell you guys just saying, you know,
I was trying to take the, uh,
the old timey door locks out of my old timey doors and my old timey fucking
house, which by the way,
I had an architect come over here. I was going to do it right this time,
you know,
for the whole fucking idea that I was going to have to make a drum room in my
garage or whatever. And, you know, the whole thing went to shit.
And I'm not going to tell you why cause I don't need the fucking hassle man.
But I just, I found out the fucking history of this house and, um,
you know, I, I didn't want to get into it.
Tony, you want to get into it? Suggest you know, fuck it. Just forget it.
I had a dream and it went in the shitter.
Um, is it, I swear to God I'm, I'm,
I'm in with this fucking house. There's no turn it back. So anyways, I'm just,
I'm just putting my head down and I'm fixing every fucking goddamn thing in this
fucking house that was painted over Jerry rigged.
Not done with the fucking,
I don't know who a fucking mailman built half this fucking house. So anyways,
I got these, uh,
these old door locks and of course some dos paid this other Douche to come in
here and he just painted over everything was, she did okay.
I don't really branded as sexist here. Okay.
A woman is just as good with the paintbrush as a man is, if not better.
There are certain studies on a scratch my twat.com that actually indicate that a
female. Um, so I finally got the, uh,
I finally got the door,
looks out of my door and I brought him down to the old fella down the street,
the locksmith guy. And I gave him three,
two of which were original and none what?
And another one was a newer like home depot style one. So he goes,
this new home depot, when I can't make a skeleton key four,
it's a big fucking pain in the ass.
I think I have an older lock from the same era is your other lock.
So I said, well, okay, let's do that. And I was like, all right,
you'll give me a shout when you, when you get these things done. And I said,
you know, preferably one key would be able to match all of them,
like a skeleton key and can I also get one those cool looking skeleton keys
instead of some modern looking key? And he goes, oh, absolutely. He goes,
that's the only key that'll work.
And guess who fucking called me right before I sat down two days later,
two days later, this guy called back. He has the locks fixed and all that shit.
So now in my office there's a,
you know, I've got two little closets.
I can lock both those doors and I can lock the main door. And then the,
when you go into the bathroom, um, you can,
uh, that one I had fixed last year, so they'll all fucking work. You know,
anyone I love about it is Nia was giving me shit going like,
what the fuck are you pulling all the doors apart? You know?
And I tried to tell her, and she just kept going, Yo, not a lock. Smith
just kept giving me shit going, you're going to fuck up the house. I go, no,
and I'm gonna do it. She kept going, Yo, not a locksmith. Um,
and then just was openly laughing at me, um,
as she does, which of course made me laugh at myself,
but I got these fuckers out, um, by,
of course,
going on youtube and learning how to like get these things off without stripping
the, uh, the screws and all that.
I found this great youtube video where this guy goes, all right,
you just stick the screwdriver in there and you give just a little bit of
pressure and then you just sort of tap it lightly with the hammer, you know,
and that loosens up the paint and then eventually you're able to turn the thing
and God damn it, if it didn't work,
it worked on all of them except the ones that I stripped from being to fucking
in patients. So I have a bit of a problem on a couple of doors. But anyways, um,
I got three of them down in this room and I got about another five to go.
And then unfortunately I, there's another couple of doors that, um,
you know, were replaced with those awful home depot ones.
So I'd like to get some new ones. And I know what you're thinking,
like Jesus Christ. But what's with all the doors in your house?
Old houses had a lot of doors, not a lot of square footage,
not a lot of big closets or anything, but the, God damn it,
they had a lot of doors.
And despite the fact that everybody back then seemed to own maybe one suit that
you got married in and you know, buried your friends in and all of that shit.
Like for some reason they had an unbelievable urge to lock things up.
You know, what would they add back then? They,
maybe they were panning for gold and shit. I don't know.
I don't know what you would have a value back then, right?
Everybody walking around looking like Johnny Appleseed,
why do they have so many do? Um,
so anyways, that's like the big fucking highlight in my day. And, uh,
also speaking at which I've watched the, uh,
the Bruins replay today of them playing the Columbus blue jackets.
And once again, another great game was great to see Adam McQuade come back.
And as much as Marshawn scoring streak ended,
Louie Erickson's has kept his going and a fucking Bruins man.
I'm not telling you I can't stress it enough. Like I was go,
they got rid of Lou Cheech and all those guys. I was like,
are going to absolutely suck this year and we are a solid fucking team.
Um, so anyway, so I'm watching the game and at one point,
I dunno if anybody watched the game,
they were doing this camera angle where it was almost at like the top of the
building. So it'd be like if he had like upper deck seats,
he could really watch like the play develop. Um,
and I just thought it was a great camera angle.
If the NHL wanted to get more course, they want to get more. Right? Of course.
They want to get more fans. They want to make more money. It's like the NFL,
I was talking to somebody last night and they were trying to claim that the
fucking Jacksonville Jaguars might move to London.
All right. And I don't mean Connecticut isn't there? London and Connecticut. Um,
London, England, like that's how we're gonna.
That's our first move to make NFL football worldwide.
We're going to take our worst fucking franchise
and put that thing on point. Um, evidently it's owned by some, uh,
I think Pakistanian guys something. And who lives in England?
I have no fucking idea. That's what somebody was trying to tell me.
I have no idea. I was in a bar. People were talking, I was nodding,
my eyebrows were up going, Oh really? Rarely.
And now I'm just telling you what I heard. I haven't looked at any of this.
I didn't even Wikipedia the bullshit. I'm telling you right now.
So take all of that with a giant grain of salt.
Throw it over your shoulder and you know,
do the Little Sammy Sosa Kiss your fingers. Ll Cool j thing. Right.
Anyways, um, and I think by, I know sitting there going,
why the fuck would the NFL want to put a team in London? Like,
why can't you just be happy being like billionaires? Like,
isn't that enough for you?
And I think they're jealous of world cup soccer because as much as the Superbowl
is this giant thing or we think it's this giant thing,
it got like I guess like 80 to 100 million views or something. Once again,
I'm just throwing these numbers out there,
but recently like a soccer or football is what I should really call it
considering that's what the world calls it.
Um,
you know, it's funny when they say they go, what do you call it?
Football when you carry it and it's just like, it's like,
I don't know if somebody had the great joke,
but why don't you call it feet ball? You know,
you'd be able to use both of them, right. If you want to be fucking clever.
Cons about it. Um, so anyways,
football world cup feat ball had a,
some game that was just some regional final or whatever the fuck it was,
a friendly, whatever the fuck they call it.
It's one of those ones that isn't the World Cup and it got like a billion views
like out of the seven and a half billion people on this fucking planet.
Um,
it got a billion fucking views. So they sit in that go,
we've got to go global with us. Shit.
And our first move was going to be descent,
evidently the Jacksonville Jaguars out to fucking London,
England to a bunch of fish and chip eating cuts. Um,
anyways, I'm fucking with you. So anyway, so I'm watching that.
The Bruins game.
So they do this camera angle from up top of the building and you can really
watch the play develop,
especially if you're like a novice fan of hockey because the fact that they're
to the side, you know,
if you've played hockey and you've gone to enough hockey games,
like you actually have to watch,
you got to know what's going on like three feet off of the screen,
you know,
like literally like you'll see a team bringing the puck down the ice and a guy
flips it into the zone and then the entire team disappears as the camera follows
the puck. Now if you don't watch hockey, you're going like, well,
what the fuck did everybody just quit? Where'd they go? You don't realize that?
Oh, it's a line change. Um, now with this angle you could do that.
And I was actually thinking what would be cool is, you know,
the NFL has those cameras on fucking why
they should do that. They should have a camera.
Like I would say that you should run a line right across the red line
that they still have even though they don't even use it anymore. Okay.
And you have one camera pointed down,
one end and the other down the other and basically you just follow the puck up
the ice. Um, as you normally do throughout the whole game.
But anytime there's like a power play or if a team establishes themselves in the
offensive zone, you would then cut to that camera and you could really,
you could basically see what everybody was doing.
Cause a lot of times when it goes out to the point you can't see what's going
on. If somebody down behind the neck, you could just be, you know,
seeing the entire thing. And then the second it fucking, you know,
the other team gains control the puck and they comp the IC.
Just flip back to that traditional view that they always show.
And Oh, freckles,
fucking brain was going when I was watching this and I was thinking,
you know what,
I bet in the future they'll have something like that and probably they'll end up
having cameras in the helmets and you'll be able to at home,
act like the guy in one of those Monday night football trucks and you'll be able
to direct your own game.
And then the NHL would have like a show us your best edit of fucking,
you know, whatever McQuaids slap,
slap up from the point or whatever and you get to to show your, your, uh,
your edited version of the fucking game. Like in the future,
just be able to flip around and it'll drive everybody fucking nuts who's trying
to watch the game.
And then there'll be an old grizzled cut like me going old school. Oh look,
the TV dictate the angles, you know. Um,
but anyways, I just thought it was like a cool, uh, way to watch the game.
And, and um, the NHL is,
was actually ahead of everybody else by having onscreen graphics.
They just came out too early and went too hard when they had the flaming trail
behind the puck and everybody laughed at him and ridiculed him and everything.
But now when you look at NFL football and they have like the first down thing is
all lit up and everybody's drawn all over the screens and all of that show.
I guess Madden was doing that beforehand. Um, I dunno,
I just thought it was a cool way, you know something.
I thought it was a good idea and then I said it out loud and I still think it's
a good idea but I really just bombed in the presentation. But I'm,
speaking of which, as far as like hockey, I guess Las Vegas,
even though they haven't been awarded a team yet,
is just gone ahead and just building a stadium that evidently is going to be one
of the best stadiums in the league if they're allowed in the league,
which is exciting and really fucking annoying to me as a Bruins fan,
one of the original six teams, the fact that we just went down to home depot,
as I've always said,
and just bought 50,000 fucking cinderblocks and built a rectangle considering we
used to play in the Boston Garden, which was one of the fucking, you know, MCAS.
I don't want to use that fucking Madison Square Garden World. It was,
it was a fucking church. It was a cathedral. It was an old barn.
It was the shit. All right. And the fact that we just, you know,
the fact that the Dallas Stars have a better fucking, you know, Minnesota wild,
they got a bet. They got a way better,
way more personality and shit to those fucking venues than what we have is a
goddamn crime. So now in Las Vegas,
they're building a fucking arena for a team. They don't even have yet.
I just saw it like halfway completed. I go, look at this, fuck,
this place looks amazing.
So I immediately started thinking like, well wait a minute.
Vegas is going to have a team. What would you call the team? Now,
back in the day, you could call them what they should be called this.
You call them like the gamblers. You know, remember the Houston gamblers,
they had the gamblers back in, uh, the USFL days.
They were the Houston gamblers. But you know, there's no fucking way,
there's no fucking way they'll do that.
They should call them the fucking Vegas gamblers, right?
And their mascot should be like this degenerate gambler, right?
Just look at some procast guy, you know? But it's a,
it's a fucking mascot looking thing. So it's, it's funny,
Kinda like being the town drunk used to be funny before they said, no,
he's an alcoholic. He has a disease. And you know, all the foster Brooks guys,
stop losing. Stop getting work. You know,
he know what's going to fucking happen.
All these fucking Goddamn Pansy fucking soccer mom,
mini van drive and douchebags, they're going to end up calling them like,
I don't know the Oh, the road runners,
you know?
Yeah.
Not even, they won't even call them the sidewinders, you know,
cause well that's a poisonous snake and you know,
we don't want to scare the children.
Yeah.
You know, I just, I don't fucking understand it.
Why can't you call them the gamblers?
You have a degenerate gambler as a mascot and then you teach your kid a lesson.
You see that? You see that fucking right.
That's what happens when you go on these goddamn casinos. Yeah. All right. No,
I'm not getting you another fucking popcorn. Yanna Nah.
Okay.
Old School parenting. Old School parenting.
Was it at one point during the game you took your kid too. You made him cry.
All right. And I'll tell you right now, the day that that ended,
there was the day that this country started going down the shitter.
I'm sorry. Anyways, what? W what do you go am I want to hear you guys' guesses.
What do you think they're going to call them?
Huh?
The maces, the Pueblos, you can't say pueblos there. Those were,
there was a native American group, so they'll get upset. The uh,
the star dust, you know,
they're gonna do that. If you can't call a team the devil rays,
if you just got to switch it to the res because people are so fucking paranoid
that if you call it the devil rays,
that one of their kids is going to get fucking a, what do they call it?
Possessed of off of the name of a fucking baseball team or what,
what horrific is great as this stadium is as awesome as it would be.
I don't know why. Like I'm,
I'm totally against teams being down in the sunbelt except in Vegas.
Vegas needs to have a team and you know what, they should be fucking shifty,
shady, any fucking thing that begins with sh other than Shitty,
you know, they should cheat. They should have like a bunch of Kentlands mins.
I don't want fucking knee breakers,
but they do seem to be the cheapest mother fuckers in the league. You know,
just old school fucking shit. That would be great. That would be great.
That's not going to happen. That's not going to happen. They'll put,
they'll call them the fucking, uh, uh, what do they call them?
Something like that.
This star dust and they'll hire the first female head coach. They just,
they're going to build it. They'll go that route.
That's the direction it's all heading. You know,
we should've known when when times square went from like fucking a place where
you could jerk off while someone mopped it up simultaneously. Right.
If some one legged freak was doing a dance in front of you to go into like the M
and m store and now they have chairs where you can sit down in the middle of the
fucking street once, once that went that direction.
How did I not see the direction? That's sports.
We're going to go and you know that everyone was going to get a ribbon.
You know, I don't know. I don't, I don't want to get into this fight.
I don't even get to this shit. What happened? I was in a great mood.
I have I to live with these fucking door locks. All right. What are we into?
17 minutes in a year, checking in on you here. Um,
what else did I want to talk about here in this thing? Oh my God,
I lost my shit. I've been doing so well with my temper lately.
You wouldn't know it from this podcast,
but all Billy's been making some strikes. Um,
I don't want to happen. About a month ago,
I started to flip out when I was in the car. No, I was in an airport.
That's right. Car Airport. When you get to my age, it's all the same thing.
It's some form of transportation, whether you're in it or standing,
trying to get on it. It's all like,
you just sorta all blends into one thing and then all of a sudden you just like,
it's Christmas. That's what getting old is. All right.
You don't know where you are and all of a sudden it's Christmas again.
That's basically what you have to look forward to. All right,
so with that depressing thought, let's plow forward. So we're in this,
we're at the airport and I went to this guy cap, you know,
rather than go into the fucking electronic,
faceless current thing that I'm supposed to, you know, that can't read my
credit card and all of that horse shit is what one person to help 70 people on
these things.
I go to this fucking guy and he ends up shooting the shit with somebody else.
He takes for fucking ever. And I was starting to lose my shit as I do, as I do.
I don't have control of my emotions. My emotions have control of me. Um,
my wife just tapped me and she just goes, given a minute. It's all she said,
give it a minute. And for some reason,
I don't know why that is just stuck in my head. And as I, you know,
more times than not, when I start to flip out, I just think, give it a minute,
take a breath, just give it a minute. And it's been really fucking work.
And for me about, you know, 11% of the time, um, which is,
you know, whatever, you know, I'm 11% better.
So last night I get in the car, it's fucking raining out here. So you know,
the Delia starts to rain out here.
Everybody freaks the fuck out because you know, they're not used to,
I don't know what the deal is. I guess there's a bunch of
fluids from cars just build up and it doesn't get washed away. So yeah,
I guess the roads are a little more slippery. But anyways,
so I'm driving to pick my wife up, right?
And I'm at this red light and I'm the third person in line at the red light.
Okay.
So when you're the third person in line to make a left in Los Angeles,
your eyes are fucking locked in on the movements of the person who's in the pole
position. And you need that fucker to make a move. Okay?
Take a little bit of risk or you're not going to make the light. Okay?
So I'm just sitting there, locked in on that thing, like my fucking pit bull.
When it hears a noise at the front door and it's fucking ears goes up and it's
such going low and it's fucking here. That's,
that's the fucking mode I'm in. And do you know, I watched this stupid La cunt.
All right. Or whatever transplant, not going to blame the city here
goes to make a left stops.
Okay. Stops the somebody in the crosswalk.
So the person stops. Okay.
And then the traffic that's trying to drive through one person is making a right
where that person's making the left.
So they're waiting for the person that crosswalk and the other person is trying
to make a left.
So this person is not blocking because both people are turning,
one's turning on the same street as the fucking lefty.
Cont and the elements go in the other direction.
Do you know for whatever fucking reason, this asshole,
like,
okay,
I don't know what they did. They just,
a person got through the crosswalk and then rather than going, I, I,
and I'm like three cars back on what Jeff? Oh fucking,
you know what they did. You never going to guess.
They backed up and got back in line,
backed up in fucking was at 2007,
nine years coming up on nine years of living out here.
That is the most fucked up moron move I've ever seen.
And you want to talk about not giving it a minute and absolutely losing your
shit. Aye. I literally was in the car.
And when you fucking fucking and then said the word that isn't acceptable now
anymore. It used to mean you're a jerk. Um,
and also begins with an f. And then what I did was, you know, it was funny,
right after I did that, cause I yelled and I had to do a show.
I reached into my console and I put a lodge in my mouth.
Okay.
And I immediately laughed at myself and saw how ridiculous I was big. Um,
I really wish I could control my emotions more. Um,
I've never noticed because I grew around,
I grew up around a bunch of fucking hotheads and I never realized like it's
finally dawning on me as I approached the fucking half century mark.
Um, it's, it's finally dawning on me, uh,
what a weakness that is.
Okay.
Yeah, I know I, and because it's just dawning on me now,
I can't really articulate it. It's one of those, those, uh,
one of those mobile,
I'm trying to think of them Hollywood movie I've seen where somebody just gets
caught up in their own fucking power and then halfway through it they're like,
wait, we're the victims. Right? We're what the fuck movie was that?
Oh, shit
was this great movie with this guy was getting picked on and then he just took
fucking control.
Yeah.
And then he started abusing his power and then the end,
he just sort of kind of dawned on him that, wait a minute, I w I w
I'm right. Right.
As he see seeing the fucking hurt that he caused other people,
and I want to say, blows his brains out. Ah,
Jesus Christ bill. You know,
that's what I got to find a dollar for every fucking movie. I lie. I forgot.
You know, I'd have a good 250 bucks.
Um, all right, let's, uh, let's read a little advertising here for this, uh,
for this Thursday afternoon, um, headspace.
All right, let's be honest. Most of your problems start with your mind. Fear,
anger, stress. Oh, Jesus, wasn't it? Was I not telling the perfect story. Fear,
anger, stress, anxiety, depression, sleeplessness.
They begin in your head, but they can wreck your life.
Um,
please include all of the following points during your read.
Why did they write that?
Okay,
I'm going to read everything you wrote. All right.
I've said this on numerous episodes, okay? But it doesn't have to be that way.
You can make a major difference in just 10 minutes a day.
The change comes through guided meditation. I need this shit, man.
With the new headspace app, man,
headspace is meditation made simple.
It's guided meditations that you listen to whenever you want, wherever you want,
right on your phone, computer or tablet.
Meditation is rooted in thousands of years of tradition and we're going to take
that tradition and throw it out the fucking window and let you do it as you
drive down the highway. Um,
you know,
recently I saw yoga instructor saying he was quitting it because like all of
the, it's been distilled down to just get in the fucking killer body,
you know, anyways,
with thousands of scientific studies that show it's positive effects,
like improving focus in relationship harmony and decreasing anxiety and stress.
Join over 5 million users already getting some headspace man for free right now.
Um,
I don't understand. Well why I would need to be able to do it.
I guess if I'm on the road and I'm in the quiet of my hotel room,
you know, as I listen to the people fuck on the other side of the wall,
I am able to block it out through deep breathing and focusing and quieting my
mind and becoming one with the universe. Hey there fucking,
maybe I'm fucking too, it's a threesome now.
Download the free headspace band app and begin their take 10 program for 10 days
of guided meditation@headspace.com slash [inaudible] the headspace take 10
program is 100% free. It's a hundred percent freeway.
To experience the benefit of meditation and your busy modern life.
Learn how to read out loud better without stumbling over your words.
Train your mind for a healthier, less stress life.
Start with your free trial today at headspace.com/burr that's
headspace.com/burr
yeah,
I'm smiling now. Trunk Club. Every bub buddy,
every bud trunk club club club.
Don't waste a second of the new year and a crowded mall.
What Trunk Club you can make 2016 your most stylish year yet and the best part
is you won't have to do any of the work yourself. You know what?
I just realized the most arrogant thing you could ever do,
you know as a rich person is your joint trunk club and that person has to go
down the mall and some psycho goes down there and pulls out a gun and does one
of those mass shootings and you still bitch that it took too long for the trunk
to get there. Even though that person went down there,
which should have been you and they had to go down there and dodge the bullets.
Oh, I don't give a shit what happened.
2016 it's going to be a game changer. Your fresh start.
Start the year off on the right foot and the right pants with the right jacket
over the right shirt. Fuck working on yourself as a person.
You got to get the outfit, man.
Trunk Club is here to handle your wardrobe so you can focus on what matters the
most. Please include all of the following points during your read
[inaudible]
many times. Do I have to say it? Trunk Club takes the Hassle,
man out of shopping by finding the best clothes for you, for you and your style.
You'll look like 1 million bucks or at least a couple of hundred and we'll
always have the perfect clothes for this season@trunkclub.com slash [inaudible]
you answer simple questions about your style, your preferences and sizes,
and you're excited. You're assigned an expert stylist, um,
who isn't working in New York City or Paris. They're working for trunk club.
Your stylist will hand pick clothes from the best premium brands.
Just approve of what you like and send back what you don't.
Just like that a trunk arrives on your doorstep.
And they went down there and they risked. They risked their lives, they risked,
you know, all kinds. I don't know. They had to find a parking spot.
You don't have to deal with shit filled with handpicked clothes that are perfect
just for you. Try them on,
keep what you like and easily return what you don't in the prepaid trunk.
Trunk Club is not a subscription service.
You only pay for the clothes you keep from your trunk. No hidden charges.
Just get just great clothes. That's it. It's fucking great.
You never have to go to the mall again. You know? All right.
Oh, I thought it was over. Call to action. Slash offer.
It's a brand new year full of possibilities and with Trunk Club,
you'll start the year off looking great and close picks just for you.
Get started today. Trunk Club was,
I was gonna say [inaudible] trunk club.com/bird that's trunk club.
Com slash bar for trunk filled with clothes.
You'll love wearing additional points. Dimension. These aren't required.
Well then I'm not going to do it. ZipRecruiter, the final one.
As a business owner, your company is only as good as the people you hire.
Well, no shit.
Posting jobs in one place isn't enough to find quality candidates.
Short staffing leaves little time to post to dozens of job sites, positions.
ZipRecruiter is the solution. I am the solution. Everyone Zip,
Rick Kroner.
Okay.
You know, why could you compose to a hundred job sites with one single click,
click be instantly matched to candidates from over 6 million resumes.
Plus Watch brand new candidates roll into ZipRecruiter's. Easy to use.
Interface with within 24 hours.
Zip Recruiter has been now been used by over 400,000 businesses.
Um, today you can try ZipRecruiter for free. Go to
ziprecruiter.com/byrd that sip recruiter.com/bar
hi,
ziprecruiter.com/burp. All right, that's,
that's it for the Reese's this week here. Um, all right. By the way,
did I mention, uh,
I told you guys earlier now you know that I'm an old curmudgeon here and middle
aged curmudgeon. I mean, I don't know if I'm middle aged at this point.
47 times two is 94 not a lot of people get to 94.
I'm an over the hill guy who's kitten who can,
who can still bang out fucking 10. Pullups Huh? He liked that day. Days,
days, days. Um, what am I saying here?
Um, I, I, yeah, I'm,
I'm one of these fucking people that I do not give it up to young people right
out of the fucking gate. I don't give a fuck how good a game you had.
I don't give a fuck how good a season you have. I want to see the career.
And you know,
that whole crown of king began somewhere at the beginning of Shaq's career with
that, that fucking, you know,
when you came into the league and you already had your own fucking sneaker,
you know what I mean? Um,
okay.
So I never give it up to people until like, you know, people go on.
Tom Brady's the greatest of all time. I still was going like, well,
Joe Montana has four rings and it only took them four times to get it.
He won with nobody's, he won with superstar teams. All right.
So until this guy does something above and beyond him,
the best he could do is be on his level. I'm one of those guys,
having said that, Steph curry is the greatest fucking shooter of all time.
I believe. I already think that. So I made it, uh,
a promise as a sports fan that I was going to try and see him this year. Um,
see him as soon as I can while he's still fucking young and he's in his prime.
You know, you've got to do that. Like I saw Jordan when he still had hair,
you know, so, um,
turns out I was hanging out at Lago last night doing a,
the great Tom Poppas show down there and Al Madrigal from all things comedy,
the creative force, the brains, the brawn, binal all things comedy.
He was down there and he's a,
he's a bay area guy and he watches every single golden state warriors game.
And he said, you know what, he goes, the warriors are in town this Saturday.
So I, uh, I woke up this morning by Dubai to Boop, I went on Stubhub,
they'll do to, to do it.
And I paid through the fucking nose for two fucking great seats. Um, yeah,
I'm going to go Saturday night. Fuck it.
I gotta see this guy and I'm going to get there early for the shoot around. So,
cause I want to see him put on a show and I'm hearing people talking about how
fucking unreal is just to watch the guys shoot around.
And it's reminding me of when I went to a San Diego Padres game back in May of
1998 I remember me, this comedian, Dan Smith,
now the Boston guy. We went down there and it was,
we saw mark McGwire and this is when they, you know,
this is when they were, uh, you know, going after the Roger Maris record,
you know,
and everybody was having Andrews Steam delivered to their house in their wife's
name. I'm actually going to look it up.
I'm going to find you that exact fucking date. San Diego Padres,
1998 schedule.
That's fucking hilarious that this still exist. That some,
who the fuck look this up today. 1998.
San Diego Padres schedule. I remember it was may 20 something.
Where the fuck was it? It was the candles. All right.
This is some fucking,
okay.
Ah, Jesus Christ. They had the games numbered rather than the date.
You fuck out there. There's a date. Sorry, I'm sorry. I'm sorry.
So sorry. Come on. Where is it? Where is it?
Right there. Go Fuck Yourself. Five 29,
1998 or five 30 or five 31.
It wasn't June. I remember it wasn't June.
I went to one of those fucking games against the St Louis Cardinals and we got
there early and we watched mark McGwire take batting practice. And um,
if there's any footage of that,
if you could have been there and watched the performance this man put on and you
still think that performance enhancing drugs should be illegal.
You're out of your fucking mind. These people are special.
These people are better than us. Okay. You know,
when you take a Prius to the fucking gas station,
do you put the fucking the,
you put premium super fucking the best gas. You don't,
you give it the shit gas, right?
You pull up in a fucking super car, you give it the,
you put the best fuel in it that you can. All right. And you know what it is?
I don't think it sees athletes fall. I think it's the people in the crowd.
We don't want to admit that. Well, you know, we are,
we're a bunch of Toyota Prius. That's what we are.
Bunch of Ford escorts and we deserved that shit food that they feed us and fuel
our bodies with.
As we sit there and just getting the Itus in the fifth ending from all the booze
and fucking hotdogs, you weight these fucking athletes. They're better than us.
They're special.
They need the high octane fuel and they should go out there and put on a fucking
show and fill up our lives. Right.
Anyways, I'll tell you right now,
I would rather watch a fucking roided up athlete take batting practice than
watching all natural one break down at 35 and remind me that I'm going to die
someday. You know what I mean? I want him to be super human.
I want that to be three times the size it was before they started their career.
Fuck that. Those people,
they're heroes they use in themselves as Guinea pigs.
They put that shit in there, bought it in and what the fuck it was.
They didn't know what the fuck it was because they wanted to make you happy.
They wanted to hear you cheer, right.
They want to see your little kid go boil. Poised is the greatest time ever.
And then they wanted to go out and have their choice of pussy after the game.
Top shelf, high octane, fucking Victoria's secret policy. And they,
God damn it, they earned it.
Okay.
All you walking around letting somebody shoot horse horse tranquilizers into
your fucking ass.
Okay.
You know, and then what do you get? What do you get?
What do you get to as a thank you, you got to sit in front of the Senate.
They make you cry.
If I was running this nation, no, I swear to God,
I love that athletes use performance enhancing drugs and I hope they continue to
do it because as much as people are condemning it,
we learn things by them using them and eventually they're going to figure out
how to make them safe. And when I'm old, yeah,
when I'm old and you guys go to see me at a casino when I am 94 and I am fucking
jacks with a full head of fucking hair. You can thank the mark McGuire's.
Okay. You could take the fucking [inaudible], the other,
whoever the fuck else took it. I don't know who the fuck I don't.
Who gives a shit? You could thank Peyton Manning's wife. All right.
If she didn't blow out her fucking shoulder taking,
those are the oven and she didn't need that shit. Goddammit.
Can somebody please make a picture of me at 94 Jack with a full head of hair
wearing a Tuxedo, playing the stardust, cheering on the Vegas Guff.
Shut the fuck up, Bill. Alright, that's the end of the podcast here.
Anybody have a wonderful weekend? Um,
I'm going to make a little video of my new door locks when I get them in there
and I'll be excited about it.
And you guys can shit all over it because it's the internet. All right.
Fuck you too.
[inaudible] [inaudible] Oh, gone crazy.
[inaudible] last night
I was sitting on a couch Bududa [inaudible] nine in my own fucking business.
Little Dude alluded.
I was watching metal mania on VH one.
Okay.
Metal Mania. Cleo.
I think my dog is sleeping with him with his eyes open. Oh No,
she just moved her eyebrows.
Yeah.
Dude. Where the fuck did you just go?
Huh?
Cleo? Whatever you're thinking about, it's going to be okay.
All right.
Anyways. You know, it's weird when my dog sees a squirrel through a window, it,
it cries like,
like it's a long lost buddy.
But if my dog is outside and there's a squirrel, you know,
if there's no window between my dog and the squirrel,
it will try and rip its fucking head off. So I don't,
does anybody know anything about dogs? What is it crying about? Is it crying?
Like, Oh, I want to let that set off. Oh, I wish I could just end.
That thing's fucking life.
You don't make any sense to me anyway. So I'm watching fucking metal mania
alliteration. This has gotta be a hit show, right?
So I'm watching this shit and uh,
at the risk of pissing off a lot of listeners,
I think most metal slash hair metal,
it arguably is the worst fucking music ever made.
Okay.
Where's the disco? I don't know why disco gets such a bad rap.
Like disco was the, is that the default example of bad music?
The Way Hitler is, the default example of, of evil.
He's the next Hitler. It's always the next fucking Hitler. Never Paul Pot,
you know, never fucking, I don't know, picking up,
I don't even know another one. You know Ivan, the terrible,
was that a wrestler? Was that a comic strip?
I know. Horrible. Haggar don't fucking know. Right. See, I don't even,
I don't even have any other examples. Who's fault is that bill?
There's a library right down the street. I'll go fuck yourself.
You know what I'm saying? Um,
yeah.
Everybody always talks about disco and how bad disco was and it just needs to be
a changed man. Right.
And like then they'll talk about like the police and all this new wave shit and
the punk scene and all that. But what they,
they completely fucking ignore is that right after disco,
just immediately the mainstream then went over to like this fucking heavy metal
music, like that was better than disco.
I think it's fucking worse.
And I think all these times where they keep saying that everybody,
that was a big change and that this quality music came out.
I don't know if that happens. I think it just, you know, you know,
nirvana comes around and they're what,
four years later everybody's listening to fucking old town or the mainstream is,
it's just this long, tragic,
just flat line of shit music. I was watching this shit last night,
shit that I used to like and that my job was on the ground.
How fucking bad it was. It was horrible. I, I actually,
I was so bad. I was like texting paragraphs to the sensation.
Joe De Rosa Capitol records, the guy who built capitol records. Joe De Rosa.
I'll actually, you go, wow. I'll get a little intimate here with you. I'll,
I'll read you the text message I fucking wrote Joe.
Oh Joe, where the hell are we? Where the hell are we?
Joe Harris slash heavy metal is the worst music ever made.
Disco gets a bad rap watching metal mania on VH one.
Guns and roses, queens, Reich, wasp, quiet riot.
David Lee Roth Solo Shit. It's fucking God awful. Yeah.
I saw David Lee Roth on,
on his a Edam and smile tour
and I saw that video last night.
Go wing crazy from day heat.
That sounds like a song Walbergs character would've written with John C.
Reilly and Boogie nights.
Remember that he will walk you and he will blow you like it was,
it was that bad teenage Frankenstein.
I'm a teenage package dad.
You're telling me that that song is better than more than a woman
[inaudible]
you know, I think arguably it's, I dunno,
I can't believe the shit that I used to watch and like I used to listen to this
shit around checks, you know,
just hopelessly thinking that this would get me laid.
Like they would think that I was some bad-ass like loner.
Beg your head.
I mean the whole fucking, the fact that I never got laid in high school,
it just fucking went away. Right in that moment.
It was like this was what I was going to do.
I wasn't going to try to make them laugh. I wasn't going to hit on him.
I wasn't going to try it.
I was just going to play this music around them and this was going to bring me
to the fucking promise land.
Looking like a fucking teenage Ron Howard. That was my game plan.
Is it any wonder I failed Jesus Christ? And I remember I would,
we watched it on a big square TV.
Um, just watch it, lay it, damn. Lay it dad.
This fucking horrific fucking music.
And my dad would come in and just have his face would just be all twisted up,
gone. Jesus Christ. What the fuck are you listening to? You like this shit.
And I thought I was a rebel. I'm, he doesn't understand me.
You know what? He totally understood. He totally understood.
My Dad called it back in 83 called it jungle music says a bunch of Shit.
Yeah,
it's totally straight up gay man. He was like, son,
this music you're listening to is fucking horrible.
And there was all these shout at the devil.
Is anybody really going to sit there and defend that fucking song? Dude
do, do, do, do.
[inaudible]
you couldn't find a game. You could fucking,
a five year old could write that on a xylophone. Shout at the devil.
Never knew why we were shouting, you know,
blacking lawless, laggy, lawless, that was his show name.
And he took a radial arm saw and he cut the blade in half and put one hat,
one blade on one of his forearms at one on the other on these leather.
Uh, I'm going to do a bunch of dishes in an evil way. Glove.
Yeah.
And we all thought he was crazy.
Can you imagine if we gave you a forearm shiver?
It was just Eddie used to throw fucking raw meat. Your the crowd.
A couple of them did.
That's why that Lady Gaga Covenant Clam in that fucking Pastrami.
It's just been done. You know, comes out in that fucking egg from Mork.
I Dunno.
Seen The nasally horror act my whole fucking life.
You know those fucking checks with the big noses. They, they can, you know,
that's like white people's answer to the big black girl who could sing a church.
We, we, what? What the,
what the check we bring to that fight is that the white chick with the big nose
white chicks with big noses can sing. I don't know what it is.
Barbara Streisand, right.
I don't know. It's like the nose is,
it's like that dome at the top of all those con con uh, concert halls.
There you go, Bill. Try to spit it out. You dumb fuck.
But I want some emails, people,
I want people try to tell me how,
uh, round and round
[inaudible] maybe tell me the musical validity that that has over like disco,
that all those people probably at Comiskey plaque when they blew up those disco
records, like fucking five, six years later, that's what they were listening to.
No buddies.
No. Boom.
That was a hit. That was a hit in the 80s
wow. Do I owe my dad an apology?
I just, I was sitting there just one video after the queen's Reich. I mean,
all this stuff that I thought was just fucking unbelievable. You know what?
I'm going to get emails this week. It's like,
I don't know what it's going to be.
It's going to be like people either going to be like, yes, absolutely.
This is going to be, there's going to be no middle ground.
I think we'll be going to 100% agree with me or a,
I'm going to get punched in the face by Eddie Trump.
I just, I was taken aback. I mean,
I've seen those videos and fucking forever.
Occasionally I'll go back and I'll look at some old videos,
but I mean a lot of it was like ac DC like shit. They can like, you know
me back in black is timeless. There's some timeless shit in there. You know,
I even watched that guns and roses, sweet child of mine, I thought,
I thought it was horrible.
Whoa.
Hi.
And that little fucking Shim Sham dance he was doing, it's just was,
oh, and then the emotion he tried to have in the end.
Wow.
Right. And they kind of closed his eyes like, ah,
I really went somewhere when I've, I was just fucking horrible.
You know, I was right there. I W I helped hold it up. Oh, def Leppard,
pour some sugar, rob me. I hated that when that fucking came out
and all the ladies liked it and he came out in his acid washed jeans.
I actually saw him on that tour, didn't I? Yeah.
Reynolds' Coliseum and Tesla opened up Tesla,
which I didn't think they were that bad. They weren't that bad.
I don't know.
I thought you supposed to go back and listen to the fucking music of, uh,
of your youth being like, wow, that stuff was all, that was awesome, man.
Remember that? And then, you know, that was the first time I tried blow,
you know, reminiscent actually first time I ever saw cocaine,
uh, saw it and saw it being done was, uh,
at the Providence Civic Center. I saw ACDC on the who made,
who tour with loudness,
the Japanese heavy metal band that couldn't speak any English yet,
sang in English. Um,
I just can't imagine the disconnect as sure.
I can't imagine like memorizing a bunch of Japanese and going and over there and
just singing it and then not knowing what the fuck I would say going out there
and everybody, like,
I have no idea what I just said. Tee Shirts at 20 bucks.
Did I just say that or did I say, you ready to rock? I have no fucking idea. Um,
anyways, so I saw them,
they opened up and uh, anyways,
we're out in the parking lot and we're drinking beers. Sticky work,
crazy driving of course, cause it's the 80s.
This is right around before,
right before mad kicked in and they used to bring like records from a fatal
drunk driving accident. Anybody else's high school do that?
They actually brought a car from a fatal drunk driving, uh,
accident dragged onto the lawn of our campus.
We want to call it a campus, a little island with a tree.
They just left it there and we all just stared at it trying to figure out how
many people in the car, how many people died. And then we just walked away.
Like, you know, when you're young, you don't give a fuck.
10 minutes later you're talking about, dude,
I'm getting fucking wrecked tonight. Wrecked that was the word. Get wrecked.
Getting destroyed. Hamot right. So anyways,
we're driving down there. Beer between your legs as you do the eighties,
you know, you fucking lifted weights all that week.
Never all of it above the waist. Curls,
fucking Bension shoulders. Nobody did squats in the 80s nobody did.
Right? So you got your fucking tight five oh one blues on with the Little Pencil
fucking legs. And then you overdeveloped upper body, your stupid gold chain,
and then you had a beer between your legs. That's how you did it.
So we're fucking going down there.
We're probably on eight a piece fucking hammered. Uh,
I was driving this piece of shit, 83 Ford Ranger.
I got like five fucking drunk friends in the back,
which was still not even grounds for getting pulled over.
You could just have people in the back like you were bringing in fucking turkeys
off the slaughter. Nobody gave a shit. Right?
So we pull in and right as I pulled up and I got a parking spot,
there was this kid, he had his door open and kind of like a Sammy Hagar
meets John Fogarty haircut blonde hair.
I remember he fucking did a line right as I was pulling up.
And I fortunately had my window up and he saw me and he saw,
we all had ACDC tee shirts on or whatever and he just got in the car was just
like,
it's like a haunted house right up to the fucking window.
And I was just trying to take it all in like, okay, he just,
how am I supposed to behave around somebody with, with Luzon, coke?
Does this guy have like, you know, Hulk Strength Right now?
Is he going to tip over the truck? Um, anyways, that was the first,
it was the first time I saw blow.
I don't even know what the point of all that was. I was just shocked. Look,
I know it wasn't all bad like the Steve Early Metallica,
you know, right through and justice for all. I know that that stuff was great,
but uh, I'll tell you it is slim. Fucking pickings.
My friends, slim pickings,
um, F
I don't even, I didn't know what to tell you.
Okay.
I mean, I even go back sometimes I try to listen to appetite for destruction.
I know that's this watershed fucking moment in that music with some of those
fucking songs,
they are out to get me so you can shock me.
Take that one to heart and kill yourself. Um,
all right. Don't want to get me a lot of fucking criticism.
Okay.
The 1980s they'll fuck it.
Eighties did I nail it though, by the way? Everyone had the five oh one blues.
Remember that button? Fly Do washed him three times and you're nuts.
Couldn't breathe. You know,
and you wonder why you've got all these fucking crazy kids that need to be on
drugs now. Hey,
what is worse hair metal or some of that fucking patriotic country music post
nine 11. What is worse to you? What is more cringeworthy?
You know, um,
shout at the devil or that, that Toby Keith,
Uncle Sam's gonna put a boot in your ass.
Ugh. Um, oh my God.
Every dime that guy made in that song should've been thrown in his face and then
given to the troops for something else or just,
and then on a partial of it would be to incinerate any record that, that,
that track was ever recorded.
The most pandering horseshit you could ever come out with,
open and Piss you guys off too much by fucking trash and all that metal shit.
You know, I have half those t-shirts and I went to go see that.
I was just embarrassed by some of that shit that I used to listen to.
Um,
oh Jesus, right up until I was like 2021 fucking brutal. What, what, what,
what redeemable thing that I have. I did listen to the Beatles, the doors,
the stones, all that white boy shit. Stevie Ray Vaughan.
I did listen to Hendrix.
I listened to all the big band swings through my dad shift from the fifties.
Uh, I had such a weird musical upbringing anyways,
which was actually good cause it was kind of all over the map.
Um,
I started hanging out with Patrice back in the day,
but was the one rest his soul got me the a,
I still remember when he got in that same piece of shit truck that I went to the
ACDC concert and seven fucking years later, I'm still driving it. Right?
Making the sacrifices. Remember that I told you,
you don't get some fucking job and go out and buy a fucking new car.
You just change yourself to your cubicle. I always kept Mike.
I put a new engine in the fucking truck,
had somebody slap that in there for 1200 bucks,
pay that down rather than 12 grand for a new car like it was back then. Um,
so anyways, I still remember,
um,
swinging by picking Patrice up and going into Knicks and he had the cassette
tape of Ray, uh, ready to die. And him putting that in,
um, telling me that this guy was going to be the next guy.
And then through all of that,
like he cured me of all the rap that a white kid liked who lived in a culdesac.
Um,
and he showed me all the, all of that shit. So I had that whole background,
all that stuff fucking held up. But the fucking metal that I listened to,
I even watched like Lawrence Welk when I was a kid,
one of the creepiest shows ever. Even that was fucking thrown in there.
It's funny,
like fucking almost 40 years later I'll be walking down the street and all of a
sudden Winchester cathedral will be going through my head when Chester could
take Robo Dododo do eel Brang and made Dow.
And am I really going to sing this? You could have done something Matt
[inaudible].
Oh my God. Here's one for you guys.
My boyfriend wants to have his four skin restored. By the way,
how fresh and new are these, uh, these emails here?
Just because it's coming from the female perspective. I love this shit.
All right. Not saying I want guys to email him, but I,
I would like to have a nice balance here. I already say enough shit.
Trash and women. So it helps if women come in trash and guys, because a,
I, you know, it'll be a nice balance here. All right.
My boyfriend wants to have his four skin restored. Dear bill,
I wanted to get your take on a situation I'm in with my current boyfriend. Uh,
I'm a girl. All right. A few weeks ago,
my boyfriend of two years told me that he's become totally upset that he's
circumcised and wants to restore his four skin via taping and stretching
methods. What,
and basically why he wants to do this is because everybody, they say that, um,
intercourse you, you lose like, I don't know, some percentage of sensitivity.
Um, when you have your four skin removed. And um,
all I can say is no guy can tell the difference whether he has a four skin or
whether he doesn't.
Because unless you got laid when you were fucking six weeks old,
you don't know what you're gaining or what you're missing.
So I don't understand why you would do this. So by restore his force can,
via taping and stretching methods, she goes, I know, I know.
It makes me want to throw up just thinking about it. I learned to tell him,
I think he's out of his mind. Uh, but I don't want to hurt his feelings.
The thing is,
I'm totally grossed out by the idea of for skin.
Penises are gross enough already. There's no need to make it even grocer.
Uh, you know, what am I the only guy that totally agrees with that?
Is there anything more fucking disgusting than a fucking flacid four skin
covered dick?
I don't even know what it looks like. It looks like a,
I got fucking, I don't know what it looks like.
I, it's just, it's fucking disgusting. I don't even have like a reference.
It's like an elephant Dick. I don't even know what to do. It's just gross.
It's fucking disgusting. Um, she goes,
obviously I can't tell him how I feel.
He's clearly having a really hard time with this.
He tells me that he feels violated and disfigured.
This guy's a pussy. Just throw this, throw this guy into the fucking pussy, Ben,
and get on with your life.
He also claims that four scans has a lot of advantage for both partners,
but it's hard for me to totally buy that considering the fact I have slept with
a couple uncircumcised guy and I didn't notice any extra pleasure.
Although I did use a condom with both guys. Yeah,
he's full of Shit. He's full of Shit. It may be more pleasure for him.
I don't know what I mean.
I think it's amazing that women will put a dick in their mouths. You know?
The least you can do is try and tidy up down there. You know?
How about having a little fucking empathy?
Okay.
I'm asked just disguise. It's just fucking extra skin. Yeah.
Nothing more sexier than extra skin. Yeah. Yeah.
It's like your Dick used to be obese and then lost a ton of weight,
but didn't have enough money to have that surgery.
They get rid of the extra and that's gross.
There's another two paragraphs,
people just preparing you for another two paragraphs of having an uncircumcised
stretch taped dick in your head. Anyway,
I think it's absolutely disgusting and totally weird that he wants to do this
and I'm starting to get really turned off by the idea of sleeping with him while
he's stretching out his for skin.
He told me he's going to tape it to when elastic strap,
which is going to tie around his leg. I know.
What the fuck is he just coming up with this shit on his own.
I told him that he should see a doctor before he starts to do this,
but he doesn't want,
but he doesn't think that doctors know much about this sort of thing. Oh,
so he's just going to take it in his own hands. Ah. Congratulations sweetheart.
You're dating a fucking moron
that just come on. This is the father your children coming up with,
you know, taking an erector set to his fucking Dick.
It was he this you didn't you do. I have to finish reading this.
I'm thinking of breaking it off with them really. Course you are.
I thought he was a normal guy,
but I had no idea he had all this freaky shit going on underneath the surface.
Anyways. What do you think about all of this?
You got to go ll cool j.
He's got to do what he did.
Okay.
You're stretching out your fucking Dick. I know. I said I'd be true.
You're stretching out your fucking Dick. So I'm leaving you go fuck yourself.
It's over. Yeah. Fucking gross.
Anyway,
what do you think all this and my justify dumping him away or would that make me
an insensitive cont no, it would make you a strong person.
All right. You go with your gut on this one.
Yeah.
This guy is trying to to do the impossible like,
uh, like he said, fucking scientist in that Michael J,
Fox movie back to the future. He's basically,
you know,
doing the Delorean bullshit with his Dick and he doesn't want to go see a
doctor. Any doctor would tell him you can't do that.
It'll be funny though was if you dumped this guy right and it actually works.
And then he starts screaming like Billy Mays on TB with his,
his Dick Stretcher and he sells it for 1995.
It makes a zillion dollar. I'm just playing devil's advocate here. You know
there's a 99% chance you're doing the right thing,
but there is a 1% chance you could be walking away from a potential millionaire.
Cause I gotta be honest with you, if that guy actually pulls this off,
no pun intended,
people's this off and he's able to do it with some household material and then
he, you know, p they, they already make millions of dollars with those,
those pills that say they're going to make your Dick Bigger,
which we all know it doesn't work because it fucking work.
That would be an international story and um,
and then it still wouldn't work because then what would happen was everybody
would take big dick pills,
even guys with big dicks because they don't want everybody else catching up with
them.
So then having a little dick would then be like having a six inch dick as
opposed to a three inch, four inch Dick. Right.
Does the math work out on that or get bumped up? You've got a six,
seven inch Dick. You just, you just regular. No, you actually got regular. Yeah,
you'd have a little Dick.
So if this guy actually fucking is able to pull this,
that doesn't even make sense.
He's going, he, if he thought he was disfigured,
now wait til he tries to fucking do this. I mean, his Dick is gonna look like,
you know when those people put that shit, their ear lobes,
they put those fucking, um, those circles circular things.
You could shoot a Goddamn fucking bow and Arrow through somebody's ear lobe and
not drawing any blood. He's going to do that to his deck,
except he's not going to have that thing in there and it's just going to be hang
out, right bill? We got it. It's disgusting.
[inaudible] eh?
[inaudible] eh,
watching chromes whoa.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa.
[inaudible] can't see you. This
[inaudible] underrated. Oh,
way down the rate for this overrated fucking voicemails leaving them as the most
awkward thing.
I've always said that I'm terrible at leaving them, but whenever I say that,
everyone else, whenever I say that, everyone else always says it too.
So I'm putting my foot down on the issue, calling it right now,
leaving a message for someone on the phone sucks.
There's no way to start your message normally without sounding like a Douche.
And then five minutes later you realize you've been trailing on and on while
saying, uh, um, too many times making you want to kill yourself,
ending with the inevitable a. Okay, thanks.
By reminding them that you still do shit. Fucking awful. Do.
This is something that's really like an epidemic in this young generations.
Everybody just feeling awkward and feeling like a Douche.
I Dunno what happened to you guys. I think this last generation of fathers,
they flipped. Like, I'm not going to beat the shit out of my kid,
not hog them and never tell them that I, that I, that I love him. Uh, you know,
I'm going to do all of that shit and you end up with these people who can't even
fucking leave voicemails.
What is so awkward? You know,
I, I, you know, I have a hard time getting off the phone. I forget.
I forget what I used to say, but I don't feel awkward.
Well, I just feel like an idiot, I guess. So I guess I kind of relate.
I just go. All right. That's it. I'm Outta here.
Okay.
I will say that believe in a message. I like leaving messages.
I sing on people's voicemails. You know,
whenever I call up fucking blob Bobby Kelly or fucking Joey roses,
I call him up and I, I'll just immediately, I'll just,
whatever comes to my mind, I'll just start singing.
Who's the cunt that I love the most?
Who's that fucker? Who eats the toast? It's Joey.
He's such a big fan. Big Derosa. What's going on?
It's built. Give me a call back. You can't click. That's it.
Why don't you try singing? You can do it for anybody.
Hey Mom, what's up you sweetie? Thanks for having me.
40 years ago I sent you some flowers.
You didn't call me.
Do you like my siblings better than me?
Click right? Why don't you do that? Try that.
Try singing first. Um, all right. Underrated. Overrated. Underrated.
Sitting down to p. If you're a guy, uh,
is it that, how old are you? Is it that hard to stand up?
What is wrong with this fucking generation of guys? You Know,
sitting down to pee.
It's actually easier and you don't get varicose veins from all those years to
stand.
There's nothing better than just pulling out your Dick and just fucking pee and
all over everything. You know, you fucking shooting the toilet paper around.
It's fucking good time. Um, anyways,
it says the guy who drives a fucking hybrid. Um, anyways,
there are many benefits to being a guy in sitting down to peace,
such as not having to hear your CIC complaint about peeing on the seat,
even though it's on the fucking top of the ball and it's not actually the seat.
Yeah. Here's a guy, he, he,
he's literally sitting down to pee, so his girlfriend will stop yelling at him.
Okay. I don't know what happened.
People a hundred years ago,
we could hit them with mop handles and I dunno what happened.
They got organized and we didn't,
and now we're sitting down to pee just so they'll stop yelling at us.
Um, all right, number two, if you like me,
if you're like me and you wake up to pee at night,
you don't have to fuck with your eyes and turn on the bathroom lights to aim.
Oh Dude, you take it all the fun out of it.
That's how you train your ear. All right,
that sounds like the back of the bowl.
Where's the water? That's the floor. There it is.
One small step. Um, number three,
not bending down to lift up the seat out. You know what dude?
You're a fucking pansy. Not Bending down to clean off the seat.
Less bending in general.
Why don't you just bend over and suck your own Dick as you sit on the bowl?
You fucking Douche. Fuck that guy peeing. Sitting down.
You know what else sir? What else is overrated?
Lifting weights. Um,
okay.
Owning a gun. Chewing tobacco. Eating steak. What else?
Drinking Scotch. Smoking cigars. Fixing your own car.
What else sir? What else is fucking overrated?
Everything that makes being a guy fucking awesome. Losing your shit.
Because some guy you don't know Mr. Field goal that really has no effect on your
life. Talking Shit. Is that all over rated? Lee Marvin,
the only thing that saved you surge, you didn't leave your name. So that,
that's the only thing that I can say is I can at least see that there was sort
of some, some sort of shame.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible]
[inaudible].